Hi, it's Babs.
(applause)
(chuckles) Drew, I am so happy to be here.
Oh my gosh. (light chuckles)
I am so excited
that you would come here.
Oh, are you kidding.
I wouldn't miss this.
Well, you are really a phenomenon.
I mean, people really love your account.
You have like shot to superstardom.
You're always on the front page
of like the trending Instagram.
So many kids love you too.
Like you're all up in the Gen Zers.
Oh well. We, you know,
I always say who would have thunk because I'm a mom
and a grandma of eight kids.
And this started actually during the quarantine.
So I was watching my grandsons at my daughter's
and at that time they were three and two years old.
So she said, "Mom, you'd be great on TikTok."
And I'm like, "I love to dance."
My granddaughters are super dancers on there
but what am I going to do?
So she said, "You're going to do a cooking show."
I'm like, "No I'm not."
(audience laughs)
And she said, "You're going to try, come on, just try."
So I said, "What can I cook in a minute?"
So I did this chicken and potatoes
and lo and behold, people actually watched it.
They commented and they started following.
So here we are a year later with 300,
over 300 recipes on the, on our TikToK.
Speaking of recipes, Babs,
(chuckles)
you've got your recipe box.
I know.
If that isn't the most soulful, beautiful object
I've ever seen, that is treasure.
When did you start developing this?
When did you start collecting?
I started collecting those probably as a new bride.
And so at that point in life, there wasn't the internet.
So we exchanged recipes.
A lot of those recipes are family recipes
that have been handed down
or they're recipes from friends' families
that my friends have shared.
But I have to tell you, Drew,
the recipe we're doing today
is a recipe that was clipped over 45 years ago.
This is the newspaper clipping. (chuckles)
(audience laughs)
So I still have it.
And it's Pam's egg breakfast
and I've jazzed it up a bit here and there.
But, but anyway, this is the recipe we're making.
So... (chuckles)
Well, I can't wait
for you to teach it to me.
I am your humble student.
(laughs) All right.
Well, I hope I live up to your expectations.
Oh, you do, every day.
I love watching you so much.
(laughs) Oh.
I can't believe I'm actually cooking
in the kitchen with you.
I can't believe
I'm standing next to Drew Barrymore.
Anyway.
I feel the same way
(laughs)
about you.
So we have eight eggs
Okay.
that we're gonna whisk and we're
not going to make them frothy, but just combined.
Okay. And because with that,
we're going to add into the milk,
we're going to add the salt and the dry mustard.
Oh, into the milk.
Into the milk.
And we're going to whisk that a little bit just to combine.
So we're going to pour that right into the egg mixture.
So we're just going to mix that
until it's thoroughly combined and it looks pretty good.
And next we're going to take all the dry ingredients.
And you know, this is such a versatile recipe,
you don't have to use challah bread,
you could use white bread,
you could use like day old bread
that's partially stale.
So I used about three quarters
of a loaf of challah and it's already cut into cubes.
And then I crumble Italian sausage
but you can use breakfast sausage, bacon, ham, no meat.
We're going to pour that right on the bread.
Okay.
And then about two plus cups of cheese,
we're using cheddar.
And then what we're going to do is we're going to
pour the wet ingredients onto the dry.
And you know, I used to layer this
in years past and get all fancy.
And I decided, you know what, it's not worth it.
(laughs)
So now I just mix it up altogether because yes, you know,
the same end product comes out and it's a lot easier.
So you just pour that in then to this prepared pan.
Okay.
And just let her go.
And then once it's all in,
you just cover it with foil and let her rest overnight.
And then in the morning, take the foil off and at 350,
40 to 45 minutes until it's kind of bubbly.
Perfect.
And then ready to serve.
Okay, Great.
And now I was like, "Speaking of,
may I serve myself some?"
Yes.
Mmm.
French time.
All right.
Oh my goodness, Babs,
I'm so excited.
So let's eat.
Cheers, Bon Appetit
Oh, cheers.
Oh, Bon Appetit to you too, Drew.
And I just salivated.
Ah. (laughs)
(laughs)
Mm.
Mm, oh.
This is incredible.
There's so many beautiful layers to the bite.
And so easy. (laughs)
Oh my goodness.
Do you have a recipe for stuffing?
Oh my word, Yes.
(audience laughs)
I like, you know, apples, and pecans,
and like lots of different things
in stuffing, right?
I would love to
like when we ever have a Thanksgiving
all we want is like stuffing.
Okay.
Oh, here's another one to throw your way, Babs,
corn pudding.
Ah, A perfect one.
(Drew squeals)
(audience applauds)
I use canned corn and the creamed corn.
You have to have the creamed corn,
Anyone who doesn't
You have to.
have the creamed corn in there,
I'm sorry but no.
Forget it.
Doesn't work.
And plus you need the Jiffy mix.
Yes, okay.
Can we do that next, Babs?
(audience cheering)
Yes, I think.
Corn pudding!
Oh, Wonderful!
(laughs)
Oh, Babs, Thank you so much.
You're the best.
Thank you so much.
Brunch with Babs
is a brunch with--
I want to get brunch
with Drew any day of the week.
Okay, great, let's do that.
(upbeat music)